[Musique]
voilà nous sommes nous au milieu donc de
cette exposition la science de replay
croyez-le ou non nous avons autour de
nous plein de choses vraiment fascinante
je voulais juste montrer ce bistrot des
insectes des bestioles que l'on peut
manger
en fait en amérique du nord on n'est pas
très habitués à manger des insectes mais
y'a pleins pleins de nos populations à
travers le monde qui mangent des
insectes donc ici vous pouvez choisir
une des idées différentes recettes
proposées dans cette galerie donc vous
allez être surpris par tout ce qu'on
peut faire avec des insectes
ok maintenant nous allons passer un
autre un autre endroit très spécial ici
très amusant pour les petits et les
grands qui vont s'amuser ici à
l'intérieur de cette petite salle
vous pouvez créer mon mouvement à
l'infini
[Musique]